authors and the publishing industry
every weekend here on c-span 2.
in a moment university of alabama french
professor william carter talks about his
new biography of marcel proust
proust was a french writer best known
for his eight volume novel remembrance
of things past in the biography mr
carter focuses on proof's development as
an artist and draws on newly released
materials about his work his
relationships and his health
um
after the
lecture he will be signing books
over to your left we also have coffee
and ice water available
in the back
genie classe
the head of our foreign language
department will now introduce dr carter
thank you
good evening
for a long time to begin with a pristine
phrase
bill carter has been an intimate of the
literary genius marcel proust
and bill has introduced or reintroduced
him to many of us here tonight through
his courses at the university of alabama
at birmingham
he even brought the daughter of celeste
albarre proof's faithful housekeeper and
confidant to birmingham to meet us
having enjoyed his graduate course on
proust and attended the premiere of his
fascinating documentary film
i was not surprised to see his book
touted as quote the most comprehensive
biography written in english in two
generations in the yale book news
bill carter knows proust that well and
despite the fact that yale university
press is bill's publisher it was
gratifying to see his book prominently
displayed in the new releases section of
the princeton university bookstore when
i visited there last week
those of us who have read the more than
three thousand pages of proof's
autobiographical novel allah
are well aware of its complexities
but when but one but excuse me but what
when one learns that bill's research
also takes into account more than 5 000
of this eccentric writer's letters
75 of his notebooks containing hundreds
of pages of drafts and several newly
published memoirs the enormity of his
achievement becomes more obvious
the march booklist review states that
carter braves the ascent of one of the
highest peaks in world literature and
according to the many complementary
reviews of marcel proust a life
bill reaches the summit and leaves his
mark
his biography is not only scholarly but
also highly readable
students
take note of what you can accomplish
when you have a passion for your subject
although dr carter didn't learn to speak
french until college his devotion to
excellence and thorough research have
won him much recognition
including outstanding student and french
from the university of georgia and a
fulbright hayes grant to study in france
as well as major grants from the
national endowment for the humanities to
produce the multiple award-winning film
documentary on marcel proust
he has been recognized by the american
association of teachers of french
alabama chapter and the french
government for outstanding contributions
to french culture he is a member of the
editorial board of the journal of the
proof society which is published in
france and a permanent correspondent of
the proust research center at the
sorbonne
the scholarship evident in his
publications have won him invitations to
speak at harvard university the french
embassy in washington dc and even in
italy
we are very honored to welcome dr carter
back to altamonte this evening he is a
parent of three of our graduates all
excellent french students themselves and
a former trustee of the school
and when kirkus reviews describes his
book as quote a prodigious work rich and
racy informed by fact animated by enemy
by imagination utterly worthy of its
wondrous subject we can anticipate a
highly informative and interesting
altimon evening
dr william carter
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you i'm so happy that
you're all here to make this evening
such a special one for me uh
listening to jeannie and jenny did a
great job i want to thank you for that
very warm and and very generous
introduction
and actually she covered several things
that i was going to mention myself and
she did a much better job than i was
going to do and also i know why i'm kind
of tired it's after all this prustian
mountain climbing
so thank you jenny for for reminding me
of some of the challenges that that i
faced in writing this biography
uh it's always a pleasure to be here at
altamonte for me and my family my three
daughters my wife lynn it really is like
homecoming and it's wonderful always to
have any occasion to come to altamonte
so i want to really thank
the altamot school martin haynes and
rocher
the faculty students and staff for
making me feel so welcome tonight
i would also like to thank brenda cole
my publicist at yale university press
and gail short at
university
alabama birmingham media services and
c-span
books too for all they've done to bring
this event to a wider audience
and most of all again i want to thank
all of you for coming
this really is as i
said my first appearance after this this
book and
this is really a special occasion for me
it's the moment that i've looked forward
to
for some time
i want to
keeping time in mind if you're at all
familiar with proofs time is really a
key word
so keeping time in mind
i want to make a few informal general
remarks
about proust and the experience of
writing this book an endeavor that took
many many years of hard work and then i
want to stop
and and take questions because really
what interests me most
is is what you'd like to know about a
proust or about this project so i'm
going to try to do something uh that is
dangerous and i'm
jenny gave me the perfect segue i
mentioned the mountain climbing i'm
going to do one of those things that you
maybe see on tv that says don't try this
at home
or maybe you remember the monty python
film where there's a contest and people
try to summarize
3 000 page novel in 18 seconds or less
and so what i'm going to do and i know
i'm going to do a very poor job of it
i'm going to try to summarize proof's
life proof's era and the book in search
of lost time and you know 10 or 15
minutes or less
now this is going to be terrible i know
this already
but the anecdote if i do this you have
to promise me that you're going to rush
home and read those 810 pages that i
wrote
in marcel prusa life because that's
going to make up for all the
deficiencies and what i'm about to do
so
to to begin with
and and jenny said this and
it's wonderful to be talking to friends
and people from the
birmingham community but all of you know
that i've long been fascinated by marcel
proust
his life the era in which he lived and
especially by his monumental achievement
in the novel
allah do and the title in french in
search of lost time is a very important
title i'm not going to elaborate on my
monty python summary summary here but i
hope some of you and and the questions
maybe we can get back to some of these
things that i'm going to go over
very fast
as jenny said it's 3 000 pages
proust as an artist took an incredible
gamble
he didn't start this novel until late in
his life and if you think about it if
you're a writer if you're a novelist to
put
everything that you want to say
in a story in a story in a narrative
that you want people to go out and buy
and spend the time
to read and it's a 3 000 page book
that's a tremendous tremendous gamble
part of that or even maybe most of that
was not intentional world war one sort
of interrupted the publication
of the book but it is an extraordinary
achievement and it is something that i
think uh proust as an artist
triumphed over this great difficulty
because he has many readers throughout
the world today who enjoy this book
despite its richness its complexity
and its length and i'll be happy to
elaborate on some of that in the
question uh section if anyone is
is interested
anyway the title in english for many
years was remembrance of things past
but in recent revisions of this
famous
ck scott montreal
translation
a translation of f scott fitzgerald
considered a masterpiece in its own
right
proof's novel has recently been retitled
to the more accurate if to some ears
less poetical in search of lost time
so i want to talk a little bit now about
proof's life in relation to the writing
of this book and this life
led after many false starts to the
production of this masterpiece
since its publication in france in the
first quarter of the 20th century this
vast novel has delighted readers in over
30 languages throughout the world
the count of the number of translations
is a little tricky because now we have a
second japanese translation the second
italian translation a three times
revised english translation and the next
year in the year 2001 there's a group of
translators at cambridge university in
england who's going to come out with a
new translation in english and there's a
different translator for each
volume of the book for each of the seven
parts so we'll have to wait and see what
that produces but all of this activity
and other things that i can mention
are indicators of how youthful and and
uh contemporary uh and energetic pruss
remains as a presence among us as a as a
novelist
uh lecturing at cornell university in
the 1950s vladimir nabakov said in
search of lost time was the greatest
novel of the first half of the century
given the abiding interest in proofs and
the wealth of fresh material available a
new life in english seemed overdue and
this is what i attempted to
to accomplish i want to just sketch out
for you briefly
some of the sources the
of information some of which jenny
referred to
available since the first major english
biography was published in the late 50s
volume 1 volume 2
in
1964 by george d painter
we have had since painter's biography
approximately five thousand letters in
philip comb's annotated 21 volume
edition of produce correspondence
i don't mean that all of these letters
were unavailable before but many of them
were and none of them were available in
painter's highly i'm sorry in kolb's
highly useful annotated edition
uh we have sketches and poems by an
adolescent proofs we have all of the
notebooks all of the known existing
notebooks a hundred plus
of the manuscripts of many of the uh
of uh in search of lost time but also
produce other works that are now
available at the bibliotech nationale
uh when proust came into the public
domain in the late 1980s
uh a
several french editions of the
search were published all with generous
notes and lectures at generous notes and
comments by french scholars and then in
the meantime also since painter we have
had letters and memoirs by people who
knew the writer and his milieu
intimately
of these memoirs just to give you one
example but it's a very important
example
again jenny helped me out here by
mentioning celeste alba
legendary housekeeper
she published her memoirs in 1973
and
this book in fact called music
inspired percy adlong's first feature
film which is a wonderful
film called celeste based on her memoirs
and celeste was a wonderful witness to
proof's daily life or perhaps i should
say nocturnal life that's a that's a cue
for a question later if anybody wants to
ask about that uh she was with him for
the final eight years of his life from
1914 to
1922. and she became his full-time
housekeeper you notice the date 1914
because of world war one all of the
able-bodied men were called up into the
service and so celeste filled in for
what had been priest was living alone by
that time
male servants
so all of these documents are the source
of many recovered conversations and
vivid recollections of proofs
and then in the 1990s there were three
new biographies that appeared in france
and these were based also that took
advantage of
these new sources that i have mentioned
so
all of this material together and i'm
again just giving you sort of the
highlights but i've certainly named what
i consider to be the most important
documents
have benefited me greatly i have drawn
on all of these
to write my biography
so this wealth of new material added to
what we already knew
allowed me to give for the first time in
english a comprehensive portrait of
proust
while my biography embraces all areas of
produced scholarship i gave priority to
the writings and to his own writings and
letters and to the memoirs of those who
knew him best
this material serves to correct or
enhance or put into relief information
we have had for a long time so that a
fuller more vivid depiction of this
fascinating figure emerges
we now know a lot more this is just kind
of a checklist of some of the things
that this new material reveals we know a
lot more about pru's adolescent
sexuality his homoerotic tendencies as
well as his genuine attraction to women
in a recently published diary a peru's
high school classmate danielle alive
recounts young marcel's somewhat comical
attempt to seduce an exceptionally
beautiful woman who ran a dairy shop
through pru's letters to his publisher
gaston galimar we know more about his
contracts royalties the process of
proofing printing and publicizing the
separate parts of his novel as they were
published and just a brief aside here
but uh the the the publication of this
novel of such vast proportions seven
parts over three thousand pages in prep
is a wonderful wonderful story and of
course i envied proust i don't ever
mistake myself for proust but when i was
working on this book with yale and yale
has been an absolutely wonderful press
to work with i thought well gee you know
for swan's way which is about four or
five hundred pages proust had five sets
of proofs of proofs bruce has five sets
of proofs and it's true that he rewrote
the novel on each set of proofs but you
know i thought well heck maybe i could
have two you know
and so the first publisher of swann's
way was ben i glassey and he was pulling
his hair out i think trying to deal with
this
extraordinary eccentric very talented
but very bizarre
author who completely rewrote the novel
every time he gave him a set of proofs
and he said proust is the most
complicated man in paris and that's a
good line to remember you know because
it was just very very difficult to to
deal with so in the 90s we had the
publication of proof's letters to his
ultimate a publisher yesterday
and there's a lot of information there
about the details of pru's contracts or
royalties process of proofing printing
and publicizing the separate part of his
novel as they were published
and also a wonderful collection of
letters
to proust financial advisor leonel hosea
allows us to document proof's ruinous
speculations and love of gambling
i don't know how much you know about
priests again i'll try to fill in some
of the details maybe in the q and a
session
but being proof's financial advisor took
a tremendous amount of courage
tremendous amount of courage
so all of these documents together uh
allow us to have a fuller uh picture of
proust as as as an individual and as an
artist
so one thing that surprised me on
putting all of these pieces together was
to see how erratic was proud's search
for the right genre the novel am i a
novelist he kept asking himself until
late in his life am i a novelist and
that even after he discovered his mature
voice as a writer at the age of roughly
34
he continued to doubt whether this voice
was suitable for the story he wanted to
tell but part of the challenge for
proust was there was really no model he
was really doing something that no one
had done before and what his his vision
of the world and his style and what he
hoped to accomplish uh was so highly
original that he really had to reinvent
the genre
to tell his story to tell the story of
in search of lost time and that is why
the i think that although the influence
of proust is tremendous
he has very few
imitators
it's hard to find someone who can out
produce proofs here
when you think about it
okay
continuing on here with them with my
dangerous
exploit a little biographical sketch a
produced life
and again the all the details and all
the good parts are in the in the book uh
peru's mother jean vale was from a
prominent wealthy family with banking
and industrial interest she was
extremely well educated spoke several
languages and was an accomplished
pianist gabrielle forrest
you will read about it in here
paid her a compliment on her keyboard
technique so i mean you know for race
those are great you must be pretty good
uh she passed her
uh
her love of french classical writings
onto marcel she could quote from all of
the the great writers even shakespeare
in english but she certainly quoted in
french from malie rasin the corneille
and
so she was the primary influence and for
proof's life and that's very much
reflected in the in the novel
proof's heritage on his mother's side
was jewish
but his father came from a provincial
french catholic family
dr adrian proust was a self-made man
from the little town of iliye which is
right near
chatra very close to chateau that's a
wonderful excursion by the way that you
can make some time but you can't get
there on the same tray uh you have to go
down to chat
you can have a wonderful visit of the
cathedral which is one of the great
great gothic cathedrals of the medieval
period and then you take a little
separate line or you can get a tour bus
or you can rent a car about 12 miles
over to elie kombre which is where
pru's father came from and you can visit
the house
that proud's
father's sister lived in that priest
used to visit when he was a child and
that now is a proust museum and it's
known as the maison taunt leonie the
house of aunt leone because the
character in the novel
is based on the aunt who lived in the
house so the story goes there are some
things that i have to say about that too
in the book but it's a wonderful
experience there to go
and you can actually buy the medline you
know there are two shops that sell those
madeleine another tip for the q and a
we'll get back to that madeleine
but the uh prus probably never
ate a mad glenn when he was in eliae but
there are two shops now that sell the
authentic madeleine
that little marcel used to eat when he
came to eliae to visit his aunt and one
has the levrey
madeleine
you know and so forth and so this is
really really a kind of a tourist
industry that goes on and it's wonderful
in
1971
this was the centennial of proof's birth
the little town of eliae officially
changed its name
they know what they're doing to elie
kombre with a hyphen and so this may be
a unique example of a real town that
takes its name now from a fictional town
because in the novel comrade is more or
less elie and more or less hotelia it's
a combination and then of course a big
contribution from proof's own
imagination
of the town of elier where his father
was from and otelia which is a paris
suburb which is where his mother's
family had their summer house so again
pardon me for being so
telegraphic here and what i'm saying but
the all the details are in the in the
book and in priests where they're really
splendid to read
so anyway
marcel and his younger brother robert
who was born two years after marcel my
son was born in 1871 robert was born in
1873
in accordance with the marriage contract
were raised as catholics
dr priest
who had a distinguished career as a
physician and public health official is
credited with having ended the cholera
epidemics that periodically ravaged
europe
this work dr pruss work involving a fair
amount of diplomacy was instrumental in
the creation of the world health
organization and uh when doctor andrea
prus died in in 1903
anyone taking bets on that would have
bet that the famous proost would have
been dr adrian pruss because by that
time marcel who was in his 30s had
really not
done anything of note
but to go back to the birth of our our
famous subject tonight he was born on
july the 10th 1871
during one of the worst crises in modern
french history
the civil strife that followed france's
defeat in the franco-prussian war he was
frail and sickly and in the early days
his parents feared he would die
the family always blamed the fighting
and uncertain and uncertain times during
the jean's pregnancy for marcel's poor
condition and emphasis infancy now the
whole subject of proofs and his health
and his phobias and his manias and his
dependency on drugs later in his life is
a huge topic
but again i can elaborate on that or you
can read
the story in the in the biography
but when he was young he did engage in
many childhood games he liked fish when
he went on holiday but he was subject to
the accidents of childhood
one day he fell down on the
champs-elysees and broke his nose i
guess we got to break your nose with
sean's elysees you know not a bad place
to do that but there's a wonderful
picture by the way most of these
incidents and people that i mentioned
there are two photo wells in the in the
book and there's a wonderful wonderful
photograph of marcel at 16 that not only
do i put in the book but i describe it
because it's such an incredible
photograph and you can see there's just
a slight little bent bend in his nose
there and this worried him to some
degree because when he was young he was
very you know he was very vain and liked
to be fashionable and good looking and
so forth and so this was uh
an important event but not nearly as
important as what happened the next year
when he was nine
on that day he was returning
with the family from an outing and he
collapsed in a severe asthma attack and
his terrified parents thought he would
die and so from then on he continued to
suffer from terrible bouts of asthma and
hay fever which greatly increased his
nervous dependency on his mother and
this becomes one of the major themes in
the in the novel and it's a wonderful uh
the way prius develops his theme and
resolves it at the end is truly
extraordinary but it is
something that's that's very important
the the loss of his willpower as a young
man and then both proust and his
main character known as the narrator at
the end of the novel the recovery of his
will power when he becomes a creative
person those are really key scenes so
proust does take a lot from his life the
novel is not autobiography but there are
many many similarities
between the life and and the work and
again i'll be happy to elaborate on that
to the degree that we have interest and
and time
time
okay
although
marcel was attracted to girls he wrote
his male classmate's letter
letters expressing recriminations and
intense affection and invitations to
have sex
many of his adolescent letters are
remarkable because he used them not
simply to express his emotions
but to analyze his feelings and to try
to comprehend his own motivations and
those of his classmates he played roles
and assigned different attitudes to his
friends and this is part of you know
proust uses early on in one of his early
pieces of writing he compares himself to
noah and the ark and he really is sick
and he can't get out and he can't live a
a full normal life or at least that's
the picture that he paints of himself
and it's true i think to a large degree
and so very early on he's living in this
kind of an imaginary world where he's
always attributing
motives and
hidden agendas and you know
things that are under cover to to his
friends
and so this practice which he began at a
very young age
combined with his extraordinary
sensitivity
allowed him to put himself in another's
place
and this served him very well when as a
mature writer
he began creating fascinating and
multifaceted characters
after high school marcel successfully
completed a year of military service and
it was during this period that he
received invitations to paris paris's
leading salon
in
madeleine le mayo salon
met aristocrats artists and political
figures now i've spoken a little bit
about his father and the very prominent
position in french society that his
father occupied and then his mother also
was from a very distinguished family and
she had relatives who had occupied top
positions in in the government again i
give the details in the book so proust
was well placed to meet many famous
people from all aspects of french
society both in the sciences and in the
arts but he started going out his
parents weren't particularly interested
in the social scene although they were
very much
a part of it or at least they could
certainly take advantage of anything
that they wanted to because of their
their prominence
adelia for example was a very close
friend of felix for who was
later elected president of france and
many other very prominent political
figures but prius really threw himself
into this social life and became very
much
bewitched by the what i guess today
would be the equivalent of the the you
know the beautiful people or the jet set
or whatever they're called now and so he
went out on all these occasions and and
met people like sarah bernhardt and
rajan
uh both famous actresses who become
models for the
actress in the novel known as la berma
and so he often attended these
get-togethers these social outings with
prominent writers like pierre lutti and
aratol france
madeleine lemail loved music and she
offered her guests the occasion to
listen to paris most celebrated
composers
uh one might hear camil sansan jul
masnaya gabriel
at the piano playing their own works or
accompanying a singer
uh in mad
in le mayo cello proust met the darkly
handsome reynaldo han
only 19 and already successful as a
composer and performer
soon he and marcel were inseparable
madeleine who insisted on silence during
performances which is kind of unusual
during the salon because basically you
know you just talked and if you happen
to notice someone who was performing
that was all right but basically the
social i remember one evening somebody
went to the opera this was one of pru's
friends and a fashionable lady invited a
friend of prus to come i don't know
let's say the opera was mano i don't
remember what it was come and sit in her
box and he said i'd love to come i've
never heard you in manoa
[Laughter]
so you know people paid very very little
attention but anyway madeleine lemay who
was a painter and who uh prided herself
on her artistic sensitivity insisted
that everyone remain silent and listen
during the performances and she becomes
the primary model for proust domineering
hostess madame vediora
who like
lumea refers to the members of her salon
as the faithful
and these little cello they're almost
like you know
sex or cults the priest
again for the q and a if we have time
it's a wonderfully comic book i mean
it's a it's a there's tremendous amount
of humor in priests roger shattuck has a
theory that since the book is so long
people think it's got to be serious
right why would you write 3 000 pages if
you weren't serious but there are
wonderful wonderful comic scenes and if
you have a swan in love which is a
little
little miniature novel in swan's way
just read the first opening pages of
swan and love where the portrait of this
particular salon
based on madame
le mercellon is described and you'll see
its wonderful satire wonderful satire of
the vanity of these particular all of
these parisian salon that proust uh
really satirizes and pokes fun at
it was in this salon le mares that
proust met robert de montesquieu
the considered irascible count who was
the arbiter of taste and the epitome of
aristocratic otoro haughtiness
he was a poet an artist and a critic and
he had already been the model of one of
the most famous characters in french
literature we small's desi
in a novel titled
against the the grain
and so montescui supplied proust over
the years with some of the major
ingredients for one of his most famous
characters the disdainful the tupertive
homosexual behold the charles
between
then to back up again into the
sketch of proof's life between his 20th
and 25th birth days
proust wrote many stories that were
published in reviews and later collected
in the volume les plesia le jour
pleasures and days which was illustrated
by madeleine lemay and prefaced by
anatol france and he got terrible
reviews when this came out because a lot
of people thought it was just kind of a
vanity publication one of his friends
said is this a book or a social event
you know
and uh so prius really for most of his
life was not taken seriously at all and
considered
just a sort of a a dilettante and a
lightweight writer someone incredibly
gifted but someone who just squandered
his gifts by
going out in society and courting all of
the
aristocrats like montesquieu and other
people who were socially prominent in
the various salon
beginning in his late adolescence
until of 1905 by which time both his
parents were dead there was a struggle
between marcel and his parents who
wanted him to be more responsible
they wanted him to
depend less on medication
they wanted him to
get up in the daytime and sleep at night
and they tried various strategies to
force him to adopt a normal schedule and
to spend less lavishly on flowers for
social hostesses and on tips ex
elaborate
very extravagant tips for anyone who
waited on him in any public
establishment
above all they wanted him to choose a
respectable profession
although priests earned several advanced
degrees including a law degree a degree
in literature and a grand degree in
philosophy he would never despite
intensive pressure from his parents
pursue a professional career
there's a letter that i i'd like to to
read um
that
illustrates sort of the dynamics between
uh proof and his parents particularly
his father i think i mentioned earlier
that adrian pruss was a self-made man he
came from a little town of eliae
his family was was was not poor but they
were fairly modest he'd primarily been
merchants and he became you know one of
the most distinguished scientists in in
france
and he was very much a self-made man and
also his mother john value
who was from a very prominent wealthy uh
jewish family and they had these
expectations you know for their
son for their eldest son and so they
wanted him to be
responsible they they thought this was
necessary for his his happiness and
well-being and so they really pushed him
very hard and so uh when he was
at the university in in paris he of
course
he and his family always went on summer
vacation and they often extended this
vacation fairly late into the fall and
so one uh year marcel returned home from
truville which is a wonderful resort up
on the normandy coast and his father has
said okay you can go to trivial but when
you get home we're going to talk we're
going to talk about careers
and so
marcel sat down one morning and wrote
this letter to his father
expressing his intentions and
trepidations about
choosing a career
and he wrote my dearest papa i have kept
hoping that i would finally be able to
go on with the literary and
philosophical studies for which i
believe myself fit
but seeing that every year only subjects
me to more and more practical discipline
i prefer to choose at once one of the
practical careers you have suggested
now
i'm sure his father didn't really
believe this but sounds good sounds good
he's ready i shall start studying in
earnest with a view to the examination
either for the ministry of foreign
affairs or for the ecole de shot
whichever you prefer
as for a law office and this is really
what his father is trying to get him to
so you see martial strategy i'll do all
of these other things but for the law
office
i should i should vastly prefer going to
work for a stockbroker and i assure you
i wouldn't stick it out for three days
this is wonderful
i can't do this but i'll do that but if
i do this i can only do it for three
days and so forth you see it
i still and then this is really the key
sentence i still believe
that anything i do outside of literature
and philosophy will just be so much time
wasted and of course in french it's tom
pio du and this is the wonderful title
in search of lost time which in french
can mean both time wasted and time lost
and so very early on we have this theme
of what am i doing with my life am i
wasting my life am i losing my life and
what am i going to do with my life so
this is very much of course this is a
universal theme i think in all of our
lives what are we in fact doing with our
lives
but with proust it was a crucial issue
both in his family and then later in his
own career as a writer because finally
his family
gave up they gave up and he still took
him many many years to
find his way
but to come back to his late twenties uh
proust wrote
he started when he was about 25 or about
18 um 18 1995.
he wrote many drafts for a novel that no
only a few people knew he was actually
working on in fact the manuscript was
only discovered in
1950
some years after pru's death so no one
knew that he was working on this
novel except
presumably his mother and a few close
friends
and it's known as jean sante that's
after the hero's name john jean
sante and proust
wrote
about a thousand pages about a thousand
pages on this book but he finally
abandoned it because he could not find
the point of view
and the plot
after he was very discouraged and gave
up that about the time he's 30 or around
1900 he
from 1905 with his mother's assistance
she knew english much better than he did
he translated john reskins the bible of
amiyah and sesame and lilies this
arduous work entailing the study of
french history geography architecture
and the bible
proved crucial to the development of
proof's own style and aesthetics
so to summarize a little bit peru's
career up until this point he had
written all of these stories and society
pieces for le figaro and other
publications he had drafted over a
thousand pages of jean sante he had
translated and annotated
works by john ruskin
and he had produced some remarkable
parodies of famous french writers so
after he'd done all of this he had
without knowing it perhaps completed his
long apprenticeship and learned much
about the nature resources and
restrictions of the french language
in april of 1908
three years after his mother's death and
his father died in 1903
marcel informed a friend that he was
about to embark on a very important
piece of work and this led to in search
of lost time although with a few
major christian detours again which i
um detail in the book
okay i'm hopefully getting close i hope
i'm getting close to the conclusion here
i want to talk a little bit about proust
era
prusa era just taking the dates of his
life 1871 to 1922
and this is a period which he depicts in
a very vivid way in the novel was one of
the most exciting and momentous in
history
his life encompassed the fundusyacula
and we all are very much aware of the
fantasy echo in the millennium moment
that we're experiencing right now
the period known as the ballet puck
which is a wonderful period of
prosperity and expansion and innovation
in france and that lasted of course
until 1914.
the belly puck ended
the last with the beginning of world war
one
charles peggy who was a poet and
contemporary priest observed in 1913
on the eve of the war in which peggy
would perish
that the world had changed more in the
previous 30 years than in all the
centuries since christ and if you think
about it i think peggy has got a very
good point
proust grew up in a world with no
electricity or central hitting without
rapid transit and mass communication
but by 1910 and by 1910
and aside the cork is being installed
he's really in the middle of writing the
novel but by 1910 he had witnessed the
advent of extraordinary innovations that
changed the way people lived inventions
at work with world war one to have a
leveling effect on french social strata
among these inventions to name only a
few
were electric lighting the telephone the
automobile motion pictures the paris
subway and the airplane
prus characterizes in his novel his era
as the age of speed
and shows in the search how these
remarkable inventions change daily life
and the way people perceived time and
space
by 1918 he had observed the catastrophic
effects of world war one
in which some of his close friends died
and
proust by 1918 he has four years left to
live but in 1919
when the second volume uh or the second
section i should say
of the novel was published it won the
pre-goncue which is like the francis
national book award it's the
the main literary prize for fiction and
he truly became famous at
at that moment
all right um a brief
plot summary here
um monty python again uh proust hero is
the artist when proust speaks of the
artist however he means the creative
person
those who give us a new vision of the
world whether in a renoir painting or in
einstein's general theory of relativity
now the first example is from proofs the
second is not but as you can see in a
moment you will see in a moment it could
be
in the novel the first long meditational
music occurs when charles swan
listens to a sonata by proust fictional
composer van tayu just let me pause a
moment on that name remember the
novel that he started in a banner was
jean sante
and now we have here the fictional
composer wonderful descriptions of this
composer in in search of lost time his
name is van tury and you hear that
which is invented
and this comes from otei which is where
the proof proof's mother's family had
their summer home so there are all these
echoes of proofs past uh
in here in in these names that you can
hear so he calls this a composer van
tell you so anyway charles swan is
listening to this sonata by this
composer van taylor
and swan is captivated by the music's
beauty as it reveals to him a universe
whose existence he had never suspected
swan begins a meditation on artists
and there's this whole wonderful
theme of arrows versus art here because
normally when he hears this music he
thinks of the great infatuation he has
for odette and this music is their
national anthem it's their song you know
so usually he's associating the song
with odette but now he's thinking about
art and artists and it opens his soul
expands his horizons and so in this
wonderful passage he calls uh
artists one calls artists like van talia
explorers of the invisible and then
later in the passage he gives two
examples of such explorers and who are
the two examples scientists andrei
marilli
so he names ampere and lavoisier as
examples of what he calls explorers of
the invisible so the hero in the novel
is really the creative person someone
who gives us a new vision of the
universe whether that person is working
in the arts or in the sciences or in
some other domain the creative person is
the real benefactor of humanity
according to produce
in in this life
in addition to presenting a historical
panorama of the era in search of lost
time is an apprentice novel you can call
it many different novels but one of the
aspects that i want to speak about now
is the apprentice novel in which the
hero the narrator as a child
becomes neurotically dependent loses his
will grows up to explore the two ways of
his world that of the landed gentry and
paris salon
fails to find happiness and love and
investigates the world of
homosexuality and one of the ways again
in the q and a section if anyone wants
to talk about this uh that priest is a
true pioneer this is the first novel to
examine the entire spectrum of human
sexual expression
and
there there are many aspects of this but
in in this particular case uh prus
presents uh uh homosexuality
as something that is normally taboo but
he associates this with persecution
intolerance in society he mentions the
case of oscar wilde
primarily
priests who met oscar wilde once but he
was very much aware of the trial of
oscar wilde as well as other examples of
what he considered
persecution of minorities and society
okay i'm think i'm about to the last
page in general the plot of in search of
lost time follows closely the trajectory
of proof's life
embracing almost the same period 1871 to
1922
pru's novel is a quest as is indicated
by the title in search of lost time
during his quest the main character
known simply as the narrator and who
often but not always bears a striking
resemblance to proust attempts to answer
some of the essential questions we
confront in life
who am i
what does it mean to be alive
what am i to make of this life
in search of lost time is about a man
who cannot write and spends his life
lost time or wasted time pursuing the
wrong paths either
through snobbery
they're sort of
moving up in the the various salon to
reach the pinnacle of parisian society
or in
obsessive of jealous jealous love
he goes off in the wrong directions
until at the very end ill discouraged
and growing old just like proust he
discovers that his vocation
is to write the experience of his life
now that he finally understands it and
can transpose it into a work of art so
it's not merely
seeing and understanding but the huge
task of how can i then transpose this
into a work of art that will delight and
earn the attention of others
so here's a here's a key moment in the
novel when the narrator understands
that
the subject of his future novel will
indeed be all of his best experience now
that he can understand it and transpose
it into a work of art and i understood
that all these materials for a work of
literature were simply my past life
i understood that they had come to me in
frivolous pleasures and indolence and
tenderness and unhappiness
and that i had stored them up without
divining the purpose for which they were
destined or even their continued
existence
any more than a seed does when it forms
within itself a reserve of all the
nutritious substances from which it will
feed a plant
like the seed i should be able to die
once the plant had developed and i began
to perceive that i had lived for the
sake of the plant without knowing it
without ever realizing that my life
needed to come into contact with those
books which i had wanted to write and
for which when in the past i had sat
down at my table to begin
i had been unable to find a subject
and thus my whole life up to the present
day
might and yet might not have been summed
up under the title
of vocation
and this is one of the key moments of
revelation at the end of the of the
novel
what we call reality or life is often
merely the product of habit
in the search the narrator says quote
that an hour is not merely an hour it is
a vase full of scents and sounds and
projects and climates
end of quote
by by probing beneath the surface and by
articulating what he discovered
priests sought to render events emotions
sensations and their rich complexity
quote grandeur for example in the
distant sound of an airplane or the
outline of the steeple of santilea
that's the church in combre the past in
the taste of a medlen and so on end of
quote
in the concluding pages of the search
the narrator shows that art of the
creative process
is the antidote to the dulling effects
of habit and in curiosity
quote real life
real life at last laid bare and
illuminated
the only life and consequence which can
said to be really lived is literature
and life thus defined
is in a sense all the time imminent
in ordinary men no less
than in the artist
end of quote
great writers not only speak to us
but for us
this book is about us
proof says in reality every reader is
while he is reading
the reader of his own self
end of quote in time regained proof's
narrator urges us to become readers of
ourselves and to take his book
not as the end of a quest but as the
beginning of a voyage of self-discovery
proofs left behind in the pages of his
unfinished book a new way of looking at
things
and this is the definition of the
christian artist to make visible but we
would not see
otherwise
the prussian lenses and the pages of his
unfinished book
give us a new way of looking at things
and he urges the reader to throw these
lenses away
if they don't
improve his vision
he invites us at the end of the novel to
take a fantastic and exhilarating trip
when he says
the only true voyage
the only bath in the fountain of youth
would be not to visit strange lands but
to possess other eyes to see the
universe through the lives of another
of a hundred others to see the hundred
universes that each of them sees that
each of them is
and this we can do with an el stir with
a van tell you with men like these we do
really fly from star to star and so
these are the artists the creative
person who gives us this visit this
vision
i'm going to conclude now just by saying
that
in spite of what he came to view as his
failed attempts at writing proofs was
totally devoted to his craft as a writer
and there's a wonderful quote here from
virginia woolf who has many wonderful
quotes by the way about proust and other
things but certainly about proust here's
what she says the thing about proust is
his combination of the utmost
sensibility with the utmost tenacity
he searches out these butterfly shades
to the last grain
he is as tough as cat gut
and as evanescent as a butterflies
butterflies bloom
so i hope
to now come back to my book i hope my
biography reveals in a clear and
accurate way how marcel proust
generally considered by his peers to be
a talented but frivolous dilettante
came to produce what is arguably the
most brilliant sustained prose narration
in the history of literature
thank you very much
[Music]
thank you thank you
well this this has turned out as i
feared it would i did not win the monty
python prize
you
on the other hand have been extremely
generous in your attention
but i do hope although time
is fleeing as it always seems to
i would be very happy to have any
questions
that anyone wants to ask about any
aspect of
my adventure
with this book
either
in the writing of it or if i can attempt
to illuminate any aspect of
proof's great accomplishment i'll be
happy to
so
please ask your questions if you if you
have any
yes
yes
would you say that priest was more
influenced by his
catholic background or his jewish
background were they
i'm sure they weren't irrelevant but
you know that is a very good question
and i think i know the answer
[Laughter]
yes thank you uh the the i mentioned i
mentioned proof's double heritage
uh the fact that his mother was jewish
and his father was catholic and his
mother came from a very prominent very
wealthy
jewish family
and and
carol wants to know
is is is one side more influential than
the other
uh the the marriage contract uh called
for the children to be raised as
catholics and this was done and
certainly uh prius considered himself to
to be french to be french to
uh to belong to that particular lineage
and you have to realize as i as i'm sure
you do based on
remarks that were made that that it's
not just it's not just jewish and
catholic but it's also rural and urban
because proof's mother's family was from
paris and natalya pruss was from this
tiny little village this tiny little
village near chantry
so to attempt to answer this question in
this as briefly manner as possible there
is no question i think that the great
influence improves life so far as his
culture his sensitivity his response to
people and things came from his mother
it came from his mother he
he adored her he worshipped her and he
never
denied his his jewish heritage so i
guess the
the profound
sensitive
uh cultured proofs if those are the
right right words
were heavily influenced by his
his love for his mother and all that all
that she taught him on the other hand
his image of himself as a a citizen and
who am i in terms of nationality uh came
from his his father so he he always
spoke although he he went prius did go
to his first communion
and he did not attend
church regularly after that but he was
he was brought up as a catholic he
certainly thought of himself as a
citizen of france and he's
very very interested in all aspects of
the history of france and genealogy and
and everything to do with tradition and
so forth so i think what you have is
really a a a an influence
from both the parents that is very
distinct
but the the great love of proof's life
without question what was was his mother
uh there was one point where he told
celeste that
if
if he knew that he could see his mother
he would want to die immediately that
was really the the what he wanted most i
think was be to be
reunited with her because of the strong
emotional attachment the great respect
that he had for her now having
having said that after proof's mother
after his mother died and he found
himself as a an artist and a creative
person then his his main reason for
living became the production of this
particular work but one can read the
novel
this is such a i know you know this but
just let me say it this is such a
wonderfully rich and complex novel and
it's
multi-layered and it works beautifully
and in the way uh proust orchestrates
and and develops and then resolves all
of all of the themes so you can read it
in many many uh different ways but one
way in which it can be read is as a
an apology to his his parents to his
mother and to his father for not having
succeeded sooner
because when they both died
he had really um not done anything that
one could point to and said you know
this is really
a person who has accomplished something
who has done something so i'm not
talking about just being a great artist
which is of course the the wonderful
accomplishment that he did achieve but
just being a
a normal functioning productive member
of society he had not really at least
looked at it you know on the surface
from the outside he had not
accomplished that
and so that's very long answer to your
question but i think both of his parents
were very very important figures in his
life
mike still his characterization of jews
was
yes that is that is true to uh to a
degree there's there's a fair amount
you know priest portrait if you if you
look at the way people behave behave in
society he often satirizes everyone but
on the other hand if you look at his
role in the in the dreyfus affair
when he came to the defense of alfred
refuse which is to this day
i mean we have watergate in this country
the equivalent in france i think would
be the
dreyfus affair when you have an army
officer who is absolutely honest and
above board and who was framed and
condemned on
fake evidence and sent to devil's island
for having been a spy for the germans
and there was all this really bad blood
between france and the germans this is
even before world war in world war ii
after the franco-prussian war dreyfus
was framed because he was a jew and
proust came to his defense and in the
novel it's very clear that he comes
to his defense
again time doesn't allow to
elaborate very much on this issue but i
think perhaps what you're thinking of is
that the
it's clear
that proofs
condemns any form
of intolerance and bigotry that is clear
what
one might hope
is that he would have come out stronger
he would have come out stronger in some
of the cases against
some of the bigotry and anti-semitism
but again no one could really i don't
think anyone foresaw what was about to
happen with hitler and and the nazis and
so if you if you read uh what proofs
writes in his letters the petitions he
signed and so forth uh he he very much
defended uh the the jews in the in the
case of refuse
and his father who was a fairly
conservative man and no one
in in in the french government really
had any reason in the beginning to think
that dreyfus was innocent but once
proust and his brother robert
began to take up the cause of drifus
they ran into a family conflict because
the father was very closely associated
with the
political figures front of the president
of france you know and he didn't want to
he he had no reason to believe knife use
was innocent so this was a
the source of a number of quarrels
within the family but proust is pretty
much i think even-handed
um
all of the characters any anyone who
exhibits any behavior uh
that is um
that that demonstrates any kind of
bigotry or obsession or
unfairness
he's pretty
raps everybody i would say not not just
the jews or any a particular group
if you follow the refuse affair in the
in the novel
there are all these hostesses who try to
use the dreyfus affair to move up the
social ladder
by
by you know people like odette swann who
couldn't be invited any place
except into madame vader assalam and
when she although charles swann her
husband who is jewish is
his pro-dre fuse she starts courting
these other women who have these
salon that are
elevated and and she lets them know that
she doesn't particularly think dreyfus
is innocent you know so she uses this to
to rise up in in society and a totally
uh
um
underhanded
way and prius is always satirizing and
poking fun at these people who
who put their own
um
selfish interests ahead of what is is
fair and just
what else okay let me take one or two
more than most top yes
[Applause]
[Music]
they probably had very little in common
but his brother did outlive him uh prius
died in 1922. his brother died i think
in 1936
and his brother played an important role
in
when priests died there were still three
volumes remaining to be published and
his brother played an important role in
seeing those volumes through publication
but i don't think they had a great deal
in common but they were very fond of
each other
yes
what was he afraid you spoke of his
phobias earlier
you name
it
well he was afraid of drafts
he was afraid of germs he was afraid of
noise
uh you know he the famous court line
room i should just say a word but we can
end on the uh courtline room here
since proust has become so famous
everyone thinks of the cork line room as
something that proust thought of but
actually
he was the third person in paris to have
a cork line room and he had two writer
friends one was a poet anna de novi and
the other who as far as i know
originated the idea was only bensting
who was a playwright and apparently it
was incredibly noisy in paris you know
it can still be noisy but apparently
during that period where you've got the
horse-drawn carriages the steel rim
wheels and the automobiles and etcetera
etcetera particularly on the
cobblestones apparently it was
horrendously noisy during that period
now imagine that you're marcel proust
and you like to ride all night and sleep
all day
you like to sleep when everyone else is
up you know banging around and going up
and down the street and honking the horn
and so forth so
it was because of his
noise phobia his extreme sensitivity to
noise that he had his bedroom which was
really the room that he rode in all
night he had it lined with cork and also
had a ceiling lined with cork so he had
a he had a number of phobias that
that you can um
you'll find enumerated in in the book
okay i'm very sorry that i have to stop
but
perhaps we can continue
another time
thank you
thank you
[Music]
william carter teaches french at the
university of alabama in birmingham he's
the author of the prustian quest and
co-producer of a documentary film about
proust's life his new proust biography
is published by yale university press
biography on book tv can be seen twice
every weekend here on c-span 2.
saturdays at 8 pm and sundays at 11 pm
eastern